noch fast einen monat so lange soll der
shutdown wohl mindestens dauern und und
länder verhandeln noch mehr home office
scheint aber beschlossene sache ein
verlorenes jahr für viele kinder geht es
wohl weiter mit dem unterricht zu hause
das wird für einige nicht aufzuholen
sein befürchten pädagogen und ein meer
von flaggen washington gleicht einer
festlich geschmückten festung rund 24
stunden vor der amtseinführung von joe
biden
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zu einem neuen von corona
dominierten nachrichten tag norbert
lehmann ist auch dabei für den sport ein
wunder doch von mir seit 14 uhr tagen
bund und länder doch offenbar gibt es
erhebliche unstimmigkeiten über das
weitere vorgehen in der pandemie bei den
beratungen werde um jede maßnahme
berührungen heißt es sollte sich im
laufe dieser sendung eine einigung
ergeben dann schalten wir natürlich
direkt live nach berlin zur
pressekonferenz jetzt zeigt erst mal an
seinem stern was sich im moment
abzeichnet
klar ist wohl alle geltenden anti virus
regeln im land sollen verlängert werden
bis mindestens mitte februar heißt die
meisten geschäfte bars und restaurants
hätten weiter zu grundsätzlich müssten
auch alle schulen und kitas geschlossen
bleiben ein großer streitpunkt neue
verschärfungen ganz offenbar beim thema
maske in allen öffentlichen
verkehrsmitteln und beim einkaufen soll
eine sogenannte medizinische maske zur
pflicht werden also ffp 2 oder ein
solcher op mund nasenschutz die einfache
alltags maske würde hier dann nicht mehr
reichen mehr regeln sehr wahrscheinlich
auch in sachen home office eine neue
verordnung soll es geben überall da wo
es möglich ist muss der arbeitgeber den
beschäftigten das zuhause arbeiten
ermöglichen das ziel kontakte reduzieren
im gespräch war dabei auch eine
generelle nächtliche ausgangssperre
die steht so nicht im aktuellen
beschlussentwurf die korona ausgangs
beschränkungen bleiben also wohl
unterschiedlich in deutschland zwar
scheinen die bisherigen beschränkungen
zu wirken die infektionszahlen gehen
zurück aber die sorge vor den
möglicherweise noch anstecken darin
varianten des virus ist groß vor allem
das kanzleramt hatte deshalb für
schärfere maßnahmen plädiert als
vorsorge aus der hauptstadt berichtet
andreas ruppert
irgendwie passt das wetter zur stimmung
vor der videokonferenz zwischen
bundesregierung und den ländern um
möglichst eine einheitliche linie im
kampf gegen die korona pandemie
abzustimmen ausgerechnet jetzt kommen
auch in deutschland neue cupid formen
vor mutationen die sich in
großbritannien vor allem unter kindern
und jugendlichen schnell ausgebreitet
haben wissenschaftler und ärzte warnen
diese mutationen sind höchst gefährlich
nicht weil mir leute daran sterben oder
weil der krankheitsverlauf wesentlich
schlimmer wäre aber es hat kranken
einfach sehr viel mehr menschen und wir
geben dann noch mehr raum für noch
weitere mutationen denn je mehr menschen
krank sind desto mehr mutationen nur das
gehen
wie also das virus eindämmen etliche
vorschläge werden im kanzleramt
diskutiert um sie dann den maßnahmen für
die bevölkerung umzusetzen so die
pflicht künftig medizinische masken im
öffentlichen nahverkehr und beim
einkaufen zu tragen gute idee findet die
linke allerdings müssten sozial
bedürftige diese masken kostenlos
erhalten
der satz für einen hartz 4 empfänger
liegt bei 20 euro für sämtliche
gesundheitskosten also das geht nicht
hier muss eine kostenlose abgabe
dringend durchgesetzt werden weil wir
ansonsten mit dieser entscheidung der
bundesregierung zu einer weiteren
spaltung führen
die bundesregierung plant außerdem eine
verordnung dass überall dort wo es
möglich ist im home-office gearbeitet
werden kann das reduziert die kontakte
in den betrieben das reduziert die
kontakte bei der fahrt zur arbeit und
von der arbeit wieder zurück und deshalb
hat das einen unmittelbar positiven
effekt beim thema schule scheiden sich
wie immer die geister
die bundesregierung will strenge
auflagen die länder wollen er durchweg
den schulbetrieb aufrecht erhalten
ausgang hier bislang offen
die ausrüstung ist parat noch warten die
journalisten im kanzleramt wie genau die
neuen maßnahmen von bundesregierung und
ländern zur bekämpfung der pandemie
aussehen ja noch es niemand aufgetaucht
bei der pressekonferenz theo koll in
berlin warum dauert das so lange woran
hakt nun besonders lange gestritten
wurde offen sich beim thema schulen und
kita die kanzlerin wollte dass sie
grundsätzlich bis mitte februar
geschlossen werden einige
ministerpräsidenten haben das abgelehnt
bisher sind ja teilweise schule
öffnungen zugelassen man hat sich
zunächst mal vertagt ebenfalls nicht
einig war man sich bei der
frage der ausgangs beschränkung also
soll es die auch bei instanzen unter 200
geben oder nicht und auch beim home
office also müssen arbeitgeber das
zuhause arbeiten ermöglichen oder werden
die arbeitnehmerinnen nur gebeten das
angebot zu nutzen auch da liegen
natürlich welten zwischen den worten
wissenschaftler hatten ja gestern abend
alle beteiligten des gipfels noch mal
gebrieft und eindringlich zu schärferen
maßnahmen geraten
aber auf einmal wollen diesen rat nicht
alle folgen ja die wissenschaftlichen
warnungen waren sehr eindeutig aber
genau das wurde von einigen teilnehmern
dann kritisiert das kanzleramt habe
keine kritischen köpfe eingeladen so nur
wissenschaftler die die eigene sorge
teilen und zudem fällt es politisch
natürlich besonders schwer härtere
massnahmen zu beschliessen wenn die
zahlen offensichtlich runtergehen und
noch zu wenig über die verbreitung der
mutierten viren bekannt ist vielen dank
für den moment theo koll nach berlin
sollte sich irgendwas tun werden sie
wieder bei uns sein dankeschön schauen
wir auf die aktuellen zahlen nach da
wurden dem robert-koch-institut binnen
24 stunden elf 1369 neue infektionen
gemeldet 989 menschen sind an oder mit
dem virus gestorben was die so genannte
7 tages incidents betrifft stehen
regionen in niedersachsen und
schleswig-holstein vergleichsweise gut
da auch in thüringen sachsen und
brandenburg sind die fallzahlen gesunken
bleiben aber auf hohem niveau
einer der großen knackpunkte beim gipfel
heute wir haben es gehört waren wieder
die schulen oder sind es noch zum einen
sind sie natürlich potenzieller
infektionsherd sobald sie wieder öffnen
auf der anderen seite aber hat der
unterricht zu hause gravierende folgen
vor allem für sozial benachteiligte
aber auch generell für bildung
wirtschaft und die psyche vieler kinder
finden klinge berichtet
[Musik]
es ist ein ständiger balance und
kraftakt ein hin und her zwischen schule
zu hause und beruf stefanie shop und
hier aus wiesbaden arbeitet komplett im
home-office ihr mann so oft es geht
zerreißprobe also jeden tag aufs neue
geht es los und mein arbeitstag der
eigentlich fünf stunden umfasst dauert
gefühlt doppelt so lange ja weil ich
natürlich morgen zur parallel mit den
kindern anfangen dann muss ich aber
zwischendurch fragen beantworten ich
werde immer wieder gerufen und ja dann
muss ich kochen und also der laptop ist
gefühl den ganzen tag an der plan dass
die schulen jetzt noch länger
geschlossen bleiben sollen
finden die schwestern mathilda und
josephine nicht gut und die lehrer
können wir halt auch mehr klären
also besser erklären und dann halte ich
das auch besser
die erziehungswissenschaftlerin
professor anja wilde mann sagt die
aktuelle situation belastet die
beziehung zwischen eltern und kindern
stark da eltern keine lehrer sein und
vor allem sozial benachteiligte familien
hätten das nachsehen
ja es werden definitiv kinder nicht
erreicht werden die bildungs schere wird
weiter auseinandergehen
diese schere ist ohnehin in deutschland
schon sehr hoch es gibt einfach familien
die nicht so gut ausgestattet sind
personell und auch von ihren
räumlichkeiten her
insofern haben wir es hier mit einer
bildungsbenachteiligung zu tun
familie charpentier hofft dass die
infektionszahlen es bald erlauben dass
die kinder wieder in die schule gehen
können
auch für die gastronomie ist krone ein
desaster das gastgewerbe hat nach
schätzungen des statistischen bundesamts
im vergangenen jahr rund 38 prozent
weniger umsatz gehabt als 2009 10 mehr
als 75 prozent der gastronomen und
hotels bangen um ihre existenz das ergab
eine umfrage des hotel und
gaststättenverbands aus düsseldorf heiko
ramms
maredo die steakhouse kette ist
insolvent 450 mitarbeiter stehen bald
auf der straße
das angeschlagene unternehmen hat den
lockdown nicht überstanden
ums wirtschaftliche überleben kämpft
auch der düsseldorfer gastronom weit
el-sheikh er hat kredite aufgenommen um
seine lokale zu retten
mit dem was wir uns geliehen haben in
anführungszeichen kommen wir im
augenblick noch zurecht aber die luft
für den und vor allen dingen schwindet
die zuversicht viele betriebe haben seit
monaten keine einnahmen und können ihren
mitarbeitern keine perspektive bieten
die gastronomen verlieren ihr personal
wir sehen abwanderung in andere bereiche
dass es verständlich
die menschen wollen geld verdienen
müssen geld verdienen aber es gibt ja
auch eine zeit nach der krise und wir
haben schon vorher ein fachkräftemangel
in der branche gehabt und wir werden
ihnen noch dramatisch zugespitzt nach
der kuchen der krise haben
gähnende leere in der düsseldorfer
altstadt nachmieter wie für diese
narrisch pub werden bereits gesucht doch
das könnte erst der anfang sein warnen
experten
das ist einfach so dass die unternehmen
das letzte jahr noch durchgehalten haben
die insolvenzen sind ja sogar deutlich
gesunken
aber das kann ich mir länger anhalten
bis mitte februar müssen die lokale
geschlossen bleiben hat das kabinett
heute beschlossen
jetzt droht der gastronomie
möglicherweise eine pleitewelle
die bundesregierung will weitere corona
milliarden-hilfen auf den weg bringen
darauf einigten sich heute finanz und
wirtschaftsministerium 2020 führten
unter anderem hilfspakete für
unternehmen und geld für den
gesundheitsschutz zu so vielen neuen
schulden beim bund wie noch nie der
bisherige schuldenrekord lag bei 44
milliarden 2010 war das am ende der
finanzkrise in den wachstumsjahren 2014
bis 2019 keine schulden sogar
überschüsse 2020 nun neue schulden in
höhe von 130,5 milliarden euro weniger
allerdings als geplant unter anderem
sind viele hilfen noch nicht aus
zeit zu denen corona plänen von bund und
ländern gibt es hier gleich im anschluss
ein zdf spezial oder sie schauen nach in
unserer zdf heute app dort finden sie
alle details sobald eine einigung steht
und auch welche maßnahmen unsere
nachbarländer aktuell für angemessen
halten
großer tag morgen in den usa die
amtseinführung von joe biden als
präsident allerdings wird die zeremonie
ganz anders ablaufen als jemals zuvor
unter anderem mit 200.000 fahnen als
ersatz für die zuschauermassen die
normalerweise auf dem parkstreifen vor
dem kapitol jubel rund um die
regierungsgebäude gibt es ein zwei meter
hohen metallzaun und eine weitläufige
sicherheitszone bis zu 25.000
nationalgardisten sind im einsatz
aus sicherheitsgründen und wegen corona
werden auf den tribünen gerade mal 1000
gäste sitzen aus washington ist runs das
regierungsviertel in amerikas hauptstadt
leh abgesperrt bewacht wie eine festung
von soldaten der nationalgarde
aus sorge vor kollaboration mit trump
anhängern macht das fbi hintergrund
checks die truppe könnte unterwandert
sein von rechten gruppen der general
beschwichtigt bildung keinen extremismus
jedweder art bei ereignissen nationaler
sicher wie der amtseinführung ist eine
solche überprüfung stand präsident trump
wird der vereidigung seines nachfolgers
joe biden fernbleiben einer frau und er
streitet mit ihm
trump kündigt an den corona bedingten
ein reisestopp gegen europäer aufzuheben
beiden lehnt das postwendend ab rund 100
vertraute wellkamp an seinem letzten tag
noch begnadigen derweil macht der
republikanische mehrheitsführer des
senats klar
trump ist mitverantwortlich für die
erstürmung des kapitols ein impairment
durch den senat rückt damit näher dem
mord wurden lügen gefüttert die
protestler wurden provoziert durch den
präsidenten und andere mächtige leute
die nutzten angst und gewalt um
sitzung zu stoppen das letzte teil des
zauns rund um das regierungsviertel
eingesetzt am morgen die amtseinführung
kann beginnen es wird eine sein wie
amerika sie noch nicht erlebt hat autos
sind heutzutage bekanntlich computer auf
rädern und brauchen also diverse
computer chips da ist der markt
allerdings im moment leer gefegt die
hersteller können kaum noch liefern
die folge konzerne wie vw oder daimler
mussten bänder anhalten mitarbeiter in
kurzarbeit schicken und das obwohl die
autokonjunktur gerade wieder anläuft zu
den gründen der misere alexander pohl ab
donnerstag stehen auch bei audi in
ingolstadt zwei montage bänder still
dringend benötigte mikrochips die
steuereinheiten der autos können nicht
geliefert werden
allein hier müssen 9300 mitarbeiter in
kurzarbeit die arbeitnehmervertreter in
sorge
die kolleginnen und kollegen haben
natürlich ängste wie es jetzt weitergeht
von den aufträgen hier im unternehmen
wie die zulieferteile sind ob sie
arbeiten können ja oder nein
grund für den engpass die hersteller
verkaufen etwa in asien wieder mehr
autos als in corona zeiten erwartet sie
brauchen mehr computerchips eine so
plötzliche nachfrage können die
chiphersteller aber nicht bewältigen
schließlich produzieren sie auch für
andere branchen etwa die tv oder gaming
industrie und so fehlt den autos ein
gehirn zentrale funktionen wie etwa die
steuerung der assistenzsysteme die
verbindung zur außenwelt der verbrauch
oder die motorleistung werden von
halbleitern gesteuert
[Musik]
die gesamte autobranche will in den
kommenden monaten an einer lösung
arbeiten
nach jetzigem stand ist es so dass wir
hoffen dass bis ostern eine leichte
entspannung geben wird und wir sind
dabei zu prüfen wie wir die notwendigen
ressourcen den rest des jahres aus die
erstellen können
dann können auch hier bei audi alle
bänder wieder laufen der kollege vom
beitrag über gastronomie und hotels
weine war seiner zeit etwas voraus er
sprach davon dass die gastronomie cafés
und restaurants bis mitte februar
geschlossen bleiben müssen dass es
natürlich noch nicht entschieden
die bund und länder haben sich nach wie
vor noch nicht vor die presse gewagt
oder gestellt also insofern ist das noch
offen wie lange die maßnahme verlängert
werden
soviel dazu und jetzt sind wir beim
sport handball wm norbert in einer
knappen stunde gehts los ja und dann
beginnt der wirklich erste härtetest für
das neue reformierte neu formierte dhb
team das haushoch gewonnen
vorrunden-spiel gegen uruguay kein
gradmesser das gegen kap verde abgesagt
angesagt ist jetzt ein sieg gegen ungarn
ankunft der mannschaft vor wenigen
minuten in diese die devise der
deutschen handballer mit vorfreude und
hoch motiviert ins wm vorrunden finale
ja lena kesting in gizeh auf was kommt
jetzt an dem deutschen team
die ungarn sind körperlich stark der
wird die deutsche abwehr heute abend
alle hände voll zu tun haben vor allem
der mittelblock vor allem johannes
goller und sebastian von haber die
beiden spielen auch zum ersten mal bei
einem großen turnier in dieser
konstellation zusammen
klar sei aber dass leute team ist schon
sicher in der hauptrunde aber eben die
punkte aus der vorrunde die werden
mitgenommen und mit einem sieg heute
gegen ungarn hätte die deutsche
mannschaft ein kleines punktepolster in
rund einer stunde geht es los aber ab 20
uhr sind wir schon live auf zdf sport de
klicken sie sich da gerne rein
ja danke wieder christliche danke nach
gizeh wie schon gesagt das spiel bei uns
zu sehen ab 20 25 und alles was vor dem
anwurf passiert das schon von 20 uhr an
im live
stream zur fußball-bundesliga heute
abend das spitzenspiel leverkusen
dortmund der dritte gegen den vierten
für beide teams heißt es siegen um oben
dran und oben drin zu bleiben
peter bosch hofft auf eine trendwende
die ergebniskrise in zahlen drei
niederlagen in den vergangenen vier liga
spielen zuletzt 0 zu 1 bei union berlin
wieder im kader das bei juwel florian
würz mit gutem fußball werden auch die
ergebnisse wieder kommen und wir müssen
versuchen auch gegen gegen dortmund
wieder gut fußball zu spielen
der bvb ist mal wieder verunsichert dem
3 zu einzelnen leipzig folgte ein 1 zu 1
zu hause gegen mainz noch ein beleg
kapitän marco reus verschießt seinen
zweiten elfmeter
sieben punkte rückstand haben beide
mannschaften auf spitzenreiter bayern
ein spiel richtungsweisend und etwas für
feinschmecker dankeschön in unseren
gefilden kommen wir zumindest ab und an
in den genuss verschneite
winterlandschaften in der sahara in
algerien dagegen ist das extrem selten
und dafür umso schöner es hat geschneit
das gab es erst vier mal seit beginn der
aufzeichnungen
der wind hat in den dünen der höchste
zarte wellenmuster aus schnee entstehen
lassen
ein schauspiel das wir ahnen es nur von
kurzer dauer sein wird
bauwerte auch hierzulande mehr dazu hat
gleich ist internen das heute schon mal
in der handball pause um 21 uhr 20 mit
marietta slomka und morgen begrüßt sie
hier christian sievers danke für ihr
interesse hier folgt gleich das zdf
spezial hoffentlich dann mit neuigkeiten
und wir sagen tschüss und wünschen ihnen
einen schönen